i've invented a card trick i've made up
a card trick of my own it's a work in
progress so we'll see how it goes i've
made a prediction
and my prediction is going to be guarded
by the jack of hearts look who it is yes
the james of hearts
so this card trick involves the ace two
three four five six seven eight nine ten
of spades brady you're my volunteer for
this i would ask you to shuffle this up
so it's all fair but yeah
you happy to shuffle yeah i'll do one of
these ones vegas
vegas style
are you happy that that pack was
shuffled brady yes excellent i'm gonna
try and make it even more happy that
you've got completely free choice i'm
just going to give you some choices as
we go along right we're going to deal
this out so we have five cards each so
i'm just going to give you some choice
do you want the left or the right
right i have the right i'll have the
left do you want the left or the right
right you're having the right again yeah
i'll have the left i mean i can even it
doesn't matter i can show you do you
want the five or the seven five you're
having the five i'll have the seven do
you want the six or the eight
six you're having the six i'll have the
eight i mean there's an ace there do you
want it
yes okay right and i'll take whatever's
left okay ten let's see what we've got
so we've got five cards each and also i
want to arrange them in order so i'm
going to ask you to arrange them
smallest to largest smallest on the left
to the largest on the right i'm doing
the same so we've got two sets of five
i've got three seven eight nine ten
you've got ace
two four five and six happy with that
great we've made five pairs you're happy
with that as well and i'm going to mark
the difference with some red cards so
let's look at the first pair six and a
three well what's the difference between
six and a three i'm going to mark it as
a three the next pair is a five and a
seven well the difference is a two
difference between four and eight i'll
mark it with a red card as a four and
difference between two and nine i'll
mark it with a seven and an eight and a
ten i'll mark that with a nine and so
i've got five red cards now what do they
add up to
16 20 25 25. so we have a look at our
prediction
over here being guarded
25. now did you feel that you had a free
choice do you feel that they could have
gone in any order did you feel that that
could have been any total i felt like
when you started turning them over and
giving me one to choose and stuff that
maybe you were starting to play funny
interesting so that was all misdirection
actually on my part it actually doesn't
matter which way i deal these out to you
i'm going to have five cards you have
five cards and the answer is always
going to be 25. that's going to be fixed
that's always going to be true so it's a
mathematical effect called prose veloc
identity it is a mathematical effect a
lot of magic tricks are maths effects
dressed up i'm going to make an appeal
to any magicians watching this video can
you find a way of using this effect
that's perhaps better than what i was
trying here i'm interested in a more
interesting way to dress this up to
present this i am going to talk about
the effect itself but i would be really
interested in finding a lovely way to
dress it up as a magic trick
but let's look at the effect itself so
we had the eight to ten and we were
shuffling up it doesn't matter what
order they're in and then we were
dealing them out five and five and again
it really doesn't matter so here's five
for you here's five for me and then we
were ordering it so we're doing smallest
to largest by the way total number of
ways we could have arranged these cards
then in this magic trick 126. so there's
126 different ways we could have
arranged these a set of five instead of
five but now we're going to arrange them
in order so i'm rearranging my cards and
you were doing the same weren't you they
were going from smallest to largest left
to right from my point of view i've got
my cards going smallest to largest and
your cards are going largest to smallest
in my side they're in ascending order
your side they're in descending order
and then we were marking the difference
nice thing about this trick
is we're looking at the differences now
you're never going to get three values
the same three values or more you can
get two values the same so the red cards
should be enough to mark out the
differences that's that worked out kind
of nicely impossible to get three four
five the same let's do it again for this
trick let's see if we get the same total
so i've got five this time i've got a
one i've got a four and a seven so
that's a difference of three two and a
nine a difference of seven and an ace
and a ten difference of nine and if we
add up these values i've got to be 25
again
so why does this work some people
watching this might want to go away and
try and prove for themselves that this
is always 25 that this always works
and you're welcome to do that if you
want um a pointer just to get you going
this is the important thing to notice we
have these five pairs that we've made
each pair contains a big card and a low
card
what do i mean i mean a big card is
greater than five and a low card would
be less than or equal to five look
this pair
is an eight and a three which is a big
and a small
this pair was a five and a six so this
was the big and the small was over here
big and a small
big small big small and even if one of
us had all the big cards it still worked
out that way it was still worked out so
the first thing we need to show is
that's always true let's just ignore the
values that i've got here and then let's
just imagine this pair they're both less
than or equal to five they're both small
cards and this argument is going to work
for any pair that i pick if those are
two small cards
automatically i know that's a small card
because it's on the left and it was
smaller automatically i know
those are small cards because it's on
the left of this one which are
automatically smaller now let's have a
look i've got six small cards six small
cards which are meant to be less than or
equal to five that's impossible
that argument will work with any pair
and that argument will work with
cards that are greater than five if you
had a pair that were both big you would
have the same problem so that's it
that's your proof there
every pair will have a big card and a
small card great now let's have a look
at the next step i mean i don't know
what order these pairs are going to be
in but let's call them big and small so
i've got big card one it's always the
big value minus the small value we're
always having the positive value being
the difference so it's always going to
be the big value minus the small value
for the five pairs that we made i don't
know what they are exactly but it is the
effect is adding all the big values
together and subtracting all the small
values so we're not that far away from
the answer then we just rearrange it we
know that we add all the big values the
big values are six plus seven plus eight
plus nine plus ten subtracting those
small values minus one minus two minus
three minus four minus five
and that is twenty-five and so it will
always be twenty-five couple of ways to
extend this we don't have to use the
values one to ten
what happens if i use values one to
twelve
or one to fourteen one to a hundred well
it turns out your answer will be fixed
as well again it doesn't matter how you
arrange the cards how you split it all
up we do that process we get the same
value
what's that value going to be you might
want to have a look for yourself but i'm
going to tell you what it is do the
general example
we're going to go one two three these
are our cards right and they're going to
go up to well there's going to be a card
let's call it n and then it's going to
go n plus 1 m plus 2 right and we're
going to go all the way up to 2n
right these are our cards then the whole
argument works just the same
so this final step here when i add all
the big values and subtract all the
small values it's going to be exactly
the same these are the big values here m
plus 1
plus n plus 2 and this will carry on 2n
and then we're going to subtract all the
small values minus one minus two minus
three minus
minus n well what's that you can think
of it this way m plus one minus one n
plus two minus two m plus three minus
three each pair would then have a value
of
n plus n plus n
plus n lots of n it's n squared the
value will always be n squared in my
example n which kind of midpoint was 5
so the answer was 25 5 squared and now
the other little twist to this
the numbers don't have to be consecutive
so my example is one to ten they don't
have to be consecutive they could be
prime numbers or square numbers or any
selection of random integers if you want
and the value i don't know what the
value is going to be but the value will
always be fixed
this episode has been brought to you by
audible and as they like to say
audiobooks can help you become a better
you certainly some of my most relaxing
and rewarding times just lately have
involved listening to audible titles
in fact there are two in particular that
i'd like to mention
both the true stories the first one is
endurance the story of shackleton
this tells the story of a group of
russian students who died in rather
mysterious circumstances while on a
hiking holiday this one's read by the
author himself and it's a really
addictive audiobook now to get you
started audible is offering a free audio
book and two audible originals if you go
to audible.com
slash number file or text number file to
500 500. if you haven't checked out auto
originals they're a real great mixed bag
of audio titles from storytellers
covering all sorts of topics
make sure you do give them a look and
again
audible.com slash number file or text
number file to 500 500. thanks to
audible for supporting this episode
riffle shuffle is this guy
you riffle them together is the way we
say it they sometimes do it on the table
this way you know
a casino dealer will do will do that
that's riffle this is called overhand
and the other one i call shmoosh